Charles bought five apples that cost
forty-seven cents each he paid with a
five dollar bill five dollar bill how
much change did Charles receive so let's
think about everything in cents since
they gave us the cost in terms of cents
so first of all how much would the five
apples cost well we got five apples five
apples we do in that same green color we
have five apples and each of those
apples are going to cost 47 cents so
five apples times 47 cents per Apple
times 47 cents this will give us the
total cost of the five apples in cents
so what's five times 47 well let's see
five times forty is two hundred five
times seven is thirty-five so it's going
to be two hundred and thirty five cents
so it's two hundred two hundred and
thirty five and just to remind ourselves
this is two hundred and thirty five
cents now how much did he pay he paid
with a five dollar bill well a five
dollar bill is going to be how many
cents well let's think about it a five
dollar bill five dollar bill times 100
cents per dollar he's essentially paying
with five hundred cents five hundred
cents so this is this right over here is
the cost and then this is what he paid
so we could figure out how much change
he needs to get back in terms of cents
so he paid five hundred he paid five
hundred the cost was 235 235 so we just
need to subtract and you might be able
to do this in your head but in case you
can't we can solve this we can do this
by regrouping we have a zero in the ones
place we have a zero in the tens place
but let's try to regroup from the
hundreds place we could take one of the
hundreds so now we have only 400 left
and 100 is equal to ten tens so we could
put a ten in the tens place but then we
could take one of those tens away so we
only have nine tens and if you took a
ten away then you put that in the ones
place it's going to become
ten and now we're ready to subtract so
we are left with 10 minus 5 is 5 9 minus
3 is 6 4 minus 2 is 2 so the change how
much change just traversée sharra sieve
what would be 265 265 cents if we were
to write if we wanted to write this in
terms of dollars we already know that
there are a hundred cents per dollar so
this you could be viewed as 2 so you
could view this as 200 cents plus 65
cents and 200 cents well this is two
groups of a hundred cents or two dollars
so this right over here is two dollars
and sixty-five cents or you could view
this because 65 cents is really 65
hundredths of a dollar you could view
this as two dollars 2.2 and 65
hundredths of a dollar or two dollars
and sixty-five cents so that's how much
change Charles should receive